monka from say my mathematical science
institute and so will tell us about
constructing expanding and generating
sales force or verbal communication
groups i also thank the organizers for
giving me an opportunity to and also i
thank all this because we have done a
wonderful job so far i have really
increased my knowledge and interest in
this idea so one thing i would like to
tell is you don't you won't find any
logic here because i don't know it much
myself it mainly comes in the
computation part of the workshop thing
really has symmetry because you get it
from groups this is a joint work with VR
whimper Tomoko pardon
yeah over so there and i would like to
thank you do for a preliminary version
of these slides we presented elsewhere
okay so first of all let's see what
expander graphs are so these are the
graphs where every subset is well
connected to the rest of the world so in
particular if we take any subset is the
edges which go out of S are some
constant fraction as some constant times
the size of s and this happens we should
happen for all subsets as of reasonably
small size
and if this happens we say that this
graph is a CH expander so we won't
directly deal with edge expansion
instead we will look at a quantity
spectral expansion so if a is the
normalized adjacency matrix of the graph
and so it's normalized so highest like
eigenvalue is 1 and the next largest
eigenvalue is what defines the expansion
of the graph if it is a constant bounded
away from 1 then we have a good spectral
expansion the graph
and there are various applications of
expander now so people are interested in
constructing families of expander grafts
ideally for each value of n but if not
for all n then at least for sufficiently
close values of them and this graph
should of course be efficiently
constructible so I will we will be
particularly looking at Cali graphs here
so these are the graphs which are
defined from groups so here for example
we have a group c6 we identify the
vertex of the graph with an element of
the group and then we have a subset s of
the group which defines the edge
relations here so for every elementary
of the group and every element is of the
subset there is an edge from J to G's
here we have a directed graph because
there is no minus 2 in the set and let's
say we put another element 3 here and we
get more edges and we are interested in
tree or undirected graph so we will also
put minus 2 here and we will actually
choose an undirected graph from this
what is a generating set of a group it
is a set from which every element can be
generated by multiplication
and it is known that every group has a
generating set which is which is of size
at most logarithmic in the size of the
group
and what we are interested in is getting
an expanding generating set for the
group
like
this is better yeah okay so what we are
interested in is getting a generating
set s for group which is which gives an
ik which leads to an expanding
calligraph in particular we say a
generating set is lambda expanding if
the corresponding calligraph is a
spectral expansion of lambda there is
nothing new about this because in fact
many more expand our constructions come
from groups so for example this one by
robots clear and there is another one by
the word Skippy lips are not and
margulies what we want so this is for
specific groups our question is about
all groups so for all groups is it
possible to get a generating set which
gives a good expansion in the qaeda
graph so the first question of course is
do they at all exist so do all groups
have expanding generating sex and answer
is yes and in fact not only that they
exist there in they exist in large
numbers so if we randomly pick a subset
with high probability it will be an
expanding generating set this is the
theorem by alone and Rockman which gives
a randomized construction for expanding
generating sets and you just have to
pick these many elements uniformly at
random from G and will get a lambda
spectral expansion with high probability
what about the randomization of this
food debris randomization is known there
is the randomization by the Dozen NGO
which give which you this general bounds
for matrix valued random variables we
gave another one which uses just
conditional expectations however the
drawback of this is that they both need
the group to be given as input in terms
of its multiplication table so this is
really wasteful because a group can be
much more concisely represented in terms
of its generating set and the question
we address here is what if the group G
is given as a generating set case now if
this generating set itself is an
expanding one we are done but typically
we may not have it and in that case can
we get another generate generating set
which is expanding
and this is this we answer this question
for solvable permutation groups and we
give a give a generating set of this
particular size which is lambda X finder
when we talk about solvable groups the
obvious property that is useful is that
they have a derived series of this form
so here we have a derived series g1 g2
g3 2g k and every GI is normal in G I
plus 1 and the quotient group Gi Gi
quotient GI plus 1 is in fact an abelian
group so how do we plan to use it so if
we have an expanding generating set for
GI plus 1 and also for this quotient
group we want to combine the generating
the expanding generating sets for these
two and get one for the group GI and
then we want to apply this procedure
repeatedly so now the problem of finding
an expanding generating set boils down
to finding and expanding generating set
for these two and then for combining
them we will see each of these steps
let's just see one step so let us say n
is a normal subgroup of G if a is an
expanding generating set for n and B is
an expanding generating set for it's a G
quotient in then is it enough to just
take a union of this a and B to get an
expanding generating set for the
original graph arenal group G answer is
both yes and no because although this is
an expanding generating set the
expansion is not as good so from lambda
here we go to 1 plus lambda over 2 so it
deteriorates the expansion and this is
not good because if we repeatedly apply
this procedure then we will keep on
losing on the expansion and finally we
won't have a good expander so
fortunately there is a result by there
is something called a randomized wearing
by Rosenman and Birnam
so the concept the idea here is that
they have this particular expansion 4G
and if we square the corresponding
Telegraph the expansion improves but
then the degree blows up and using de
randomized squaring we precisely why to
blow up in the degree and we still
improve expansion so from this size by
generating set now grows to a constant
factor of this and we get a lambda
expansion as we need and as it turns out
this constant factor doesn't harm us
much we still get a reasonable expire in
there
so we have seen one step where we get an
expanding generating set for a normal
subgroup and a quotient group and from
that we get an expanding generating set
for the original group and now we
recursively want to apply this procedure
because we apply this procedure to get
an expanding generating set of this
particular size where now we it remains
to get this AI which is an expanding
generating set for the quotient group
now this quotient group is abelian and
we expect that it might be easier to
deal with abelian groups then with non
abelian ones so this is good because the
length of the derived series is just
logarithmic in n note that the size of
the group itself could be as large as n
factorial so still this series is quite
short and in fact this leads us to an
expanding generating set of this
particular size
oh so now the only question we have to
address is how to get expanding
generating sex for the abelian quotient
groups okay here we have we use a result
which says that or or any such abelian
quotient group G quotient n we have a
homomorphism with an on to homomorphism
from this group onto this decotion in
well why is this useful because there is
another result which says that if we
have an expanding generating set for
this that also gives an expanding
generating set for this so in particular
if there is a homomorphism from h1 to h2
then a generating set for h1 can simply
be transformed into a generating set for
h2 by taking its image under the
homomorphism so from Chicco Shanta now
we have come to this product group and
how do we get still an expanding
generating set for this product to
bigger because this product group
happens to be a billion we can have
similar series for this just like we had
for the original group G and we will
apply the same procedure repeatedly so
look at the normal series for this where
the quotient group is fixed and it is
only this GP 1 to the N up to GPT I do
then
so this is a slightly simpler book than
the original one and we need to get an
expanding generating site for this one I
mean how and that the answer is apply
the same thing is apply the same
procedure because city also the size
relation is very nice here that is if we
have a sizes expanding generating set
for this then we have s times some poly
log factors which are getting set for
this while going from one group to
another here we don't lose much on the
size
so that other goal is to come to come
close to the randomized construction we
will not achieve as much here but still
we are keeping the size reasonably low
now for this group also we again apply
the same procedure that is again this
group has a derived series and the
quotient group here is a much simpler
one that is CP one cross CP to cross up
to CP k if we have a finding the other
ratings and clear four sides is we have
one of n square s here so these
constructions are not very simple that
for illustrating here but indeed yeah I
don't think I can go into much detail of
these constructions now comes this
simple group by simple I don't mean in
mathematical sense but just the one
which looks simple and there is a result
by higher and others which says that for
this for the group CP
a group ziti we have an expanding
generating set for every constant lambda
and that is of size almost logarithmic
in T and now this zp1 cross equal to
cross C PK that is isomorphic to C T for
T equal to product of those things so we
can actually construct an expanding
generating set for that group
today that son and I finished our limit
oh so this was for solvable groups and
what do we know about more general
permutation groups so in a we can't have
a series like this for general
permutation groups but in fact if we
applied a randomized wearing repeatedly
using some suitable graphs for squaring
then actually we get some expanding
generating set for it but the parameter
is pretty bad so it is here it was n
square and in terms of for general
permutation groups we get something like
n to the C for a large constant C and it
will be interesting to see something
that comes closer to the randomized one
so because the group G has size at most
n factorial one would expect that an N
log n size generating set should be
possible but then we don't know how to
get it our construction also gives an
improved construction of epsilon by
spaces over C D to the N I don't go into
the details here
just to make sure I understand correctly
the groups are presented by giving the
genitive thus generating set s and these
generators are given s permutations of 1
through n when you take let's start
forming the derive choose just one step
take the candidate or something such a
thing
is there a useful balance for how many
generators are going to be needed for
the commutator subgroup a priori it
could be quadratic in the in the
original group but surely something
better than that must be happening
because otherwise when you did write it
gets big so the question is if I if I
have a reasonable number of generators
giving me 3 or 3/1 then if I don't know
any group theory and I just look at the
definition the number of generators I
need 42 could be quadratic in that and
for G 3 is another quadratic and by the
time I get what's GK is trivial but
somewhere in the middle I could have
awful lot of generators theoretic
information that says no I shouldn't
worry about that it's going to be ok and
so I don't know exactly about the sizes
of these generating sites but what I
know is that looks has given a
polynomial time algorithm to actually
compute this derived series yeah unless
then another thing that blows up too
much we are not worried about it because
anyway we want to we just want to use it
for getting the information about the
group
and so have you studied some special
classes of not-so-little loops like
cultivating okay